bonjour oui c'est Valentin Maria Enders
assistante personnelle c'est tu vas
être partout sur elle tu te rends compte que
je suis sur un développement tu as eu une interview
avec un magazine italien ciblant
la session des femmes actives après 40 ans non
peu la couverture Oh Klaus sympa à
Je te vois, c'est un grand réalisateur, écoute-le juste
J'ai joué Secret in my Lotus night quand
j'avais 18 ans pour moi c'était plus que faux
parce que tu étais secret seulement tu peux te
cacher seul la pièce raconte une histoire simple
une femme plus âgée tombe amoureuse  avec une
fille intrigante qui a un petit doigt enroulé autour de
son petit doigt alors qui va jouer la
cigarette aux femmes d'autres elle a 19 ans je
jouerai celle qui la pousse au
suicide ne pense pas qu'elle est probablement mon
actrice préférée tu veux dire plus que moi
[Musique]
c'est  incroyablement courageux de votre part d'assumer
le rôle d'Helena c'est une façon de gérer
le temps je ne pense pas que ce soit les
chiffres de l'entreprise qui vous empêchent de dormir la nuit
ça me garde éveillé dans le désir pour moi je
pense
[Musique]
pouvez-vous partir wi  sans me regarder comme
si je n'existais pas
[Musique]
alors-donc
je ne sais pas pourquoi je dois
m'infliger ça pour signer un contrat polygala
coûte
quelque chose
tu fais la pièce et tu la détestes tu
ne'  Je n'ai pas à m'en prendre à moi, il
se fait écrire de la merde méchante sur moi Je
pourrais honnêtement m'en soucier moins
fois combine tu peux l'accepter
moi non plus je suppose que
toi